- I wrote an open letter
in Pollstar this year,
which is like the touring magazine,
and I had just had this situation
where for the first time,
I've got my wife who's pregnant
with another little girl
and I'm like thinking,
I seeing how different
my wife's experience
is to mine.
Just like, very, very,
drastically different
- First of all, thank
you for paying attention.
- Completely different.
- Yeah.
- So then I'm thinking about that on tour
and I'm like, man, I've never just asked
the women on my tour,
"What can I do differently
for you on this tour?"
So I got 'em all together in a room,
and I was just like,
"Hey, is there anything
"different I can do?
"Is there anything different for women
"that I can do to make this better?"
- That I'm not thinking of.
- That I'm not think of.
And they gave me a couple things
that could be done better.
One of 'em was trash cans on the tour bus
with lids.
(audience laughing)
Because,
I would never have thought of that.
- Yeah, but just so you
know, like, you know,
sometimes we have a certain time of month,
and you want a lid on the trash can.
- That's what I'm saying.
And I never knew it, like,
that would have never crossed my mind.
- Well, you don't wear tampons.
- Exactly, I don't wear tampons.
(audience laughing)
- Unless you do, I don't know!
- So they go around and
they each share something
that could be helpful
and then they each went around
and said, like, "No one's
asked me this before."
- Yeah.
- And I'm just like, "What?
"No one's ever asked you this before.
"That's insane.
"You guys have all been touring forever.
"How has this not happened?"
And then I'm looking back at myself.
I've been touring for eight years.
I've never asked you this before.
What the hell is going on?
Why, what's the disconnect?
Like, I think I'm a good guy
and I've never asked you this before.
So then I'm like, man, I gotta share this
and I wrote this open letter
and tried to share it in
the touring community.
You know my mom was an amazing woman
who helped to, tried to empower
as many women as possible.
And she would always read this quote to me
about that the world of humanity is like,
has two wings, male and female,
and unless they're both strong
the bird can't fly.
So--
- You're mom is great!
She's dope, she's really dope.
- Wow!
- And
it's like not revolutionary
but when men stick up for women
with a pure intent it
just makes me emotional.
But, it's really important
and there's not enough of it.
- And why you're getting emotional
is 'cause you now have,
you have a baby girl.
- I've got two girls.
- Yeah, a baby girl.
- Yeah, I have two girls.
Yeah, it's important.